you had friendships and conversations
with a lot of
the fascinating figures of the past
20 30 years of the great intellectuals
one of which
perhaps one of the greats is christopher
hitchens what have you learned
uh from your conversation your
friendship
so there are a lot of views he held that
i really did not agree with but he was a
remarkable person that was a good line
about north korea he was full of
incredibly good lines well one of the
things i learned was you can't win a
debate with christopher one of the
reasons you can't win is because he has
this british baritone
and this ready wit
that
um because you can't you you can't
triumph over laughter
it doesn't matter if your argument is
better if your quip is better you win
yeah and so i remember once we were
arguing about free will and he said well
i choose to believe in it and everybody
laughed and that was
yeah despite the fact that that's not
really an argument or like uh i have
free will because i don't have a choice
right exactly and people should watch
your conversation with him it's great i
mean it's a it's a kind of david versus
goliath situation and you're quite
uh masterful
at uh using charisma and sweet talking
christopher hitchens
i also genuinely liked him i i mean i i
i i spent uh a three-hour
limousine ride with him from one debate
to another from from la descent to san
diego and the entire time his he said we
just can't talk about religion yeah so
we talked about literature and he gave
me a long lecture about scotch um
he was he was
inexhaustible
i mean not only did he uh i began i
wrote a couple of obituaries about him
and one i began with the the um
historian keith thomas said there are
two ways of achieving immortality by
doing things worth remembering or saying
things worth remembering and by that
standard he did both
i mean he went all around the world to
all sorts of danger zones he knew like
the best bars everywhere from kuala
lumpur you know to beirut to l.a
and he could drink all night and
write a 2 000 word essay on the poetry
of yates and go to sleep
i remember before one of our debates in
boston he was at the bar
and he said come have a drink and i said
i'm gonna have a drink before i go to
debate with you
what are you crazy and he said just have
a beer it's water
um so
he was uh
he really was a constant inexhaustible
fountain
of of intrigue and interest what kind of
things
if you can remember if you can mention
if you can admit yeah to have him
enlightening you or helping you change
your mind about something in this world
so i think um
unrelated to scotch oh yeah unrelated to
scotch he convinced me
that the
idea
i mean i had my doubts about it and have
my doubts about it but he convinced me
through many debates not only he that
the idea that religion makes people
better
is a
is not it's not
ipso fact or wrong but it's a much much
more complicated argument
than i wished it to be
so he is
however you conceive of the term beauty
um he's one of those one of the more
beautiful
humans yes this this weird little earth
produced
so
how do you explain
the atheism combined with such a
beautiful mind
so from your perspective
of of a man of faith
um how do you think about that
so
of the atheists that i have debated
um
they i think about all of them somewhat
differently
so
i think that in in some deep way for
example sam harris is a religious
personality
i don't even think that he would he
wouldn't like the word religious but i
don't even think that he would
take issue with that um i think that he
would say his is a purely material
based spirituality but i mean his
his orientation towards meditation and
and appreciation of buddhism there's
something deeply seeking spiritual about
him
um
with hitchens
i honestly and and i know that some of
his fans will really not like this uh
it's not that he was any kind of closet
believer not certainly not at all but i
almost feel as though
he was less a passionate arguer against
religion then he was first of all
extremely upset by the forms that
religion took in this world
and then once he trained his
intellectual howitzers on a target
he had so much fun inventing new
arguments and
and attacking it
that i really believe he gets carried
away sometimes by his own eloquence and
uh
and intellectual range
so for example the idea that you would
call a book that religion poisons
everything
um i think he did that deliberately
provocatively so that he could defend a
proposition that obviously is
indefensible that it poisons everything
um
so
i don't know i think he had tremendous
job of you that's really what that's
what sums him up this guy loved life in
all of its manifestations and
and arguing against something that
someone else believed was one of his
greatest joys
yeah and and of course the practical
aspect of that he just saw the powerful
and he challenged them with humor
absolutely and you know you could argue
perhaps that humor is the highest form
of what humanity can achieve like
sometimes maybe us
little
humans take things a little too
seriously then sometimes we need to just
laugh at it all laugh at ourselves and
that's probably the the purest form of
wisdom you know auden the poet said
among the people that i like or admire i
can find no common quality but among
those i love i can all of them make me
laugh
you